So, I made a little over $4,500 with
this trade I took right here. And
instead of walking you through and just
showing you the live recording of it, I
want to kind of do a recap to walk you
through why I jumped into this trade.
It's a little bit different than normal.
And to show you some of the levels I'm
looking at and how, you know, I kind of
jumped in here on a trade and was able
to capture, you know, a really nice
three times my profit at like $4,500
for the day. And so what I want to look
at here is first off, as always with
every trade I'm looking at, just to show
you kind of big picture here, is this
support level I took a trade off of. was
this right here. The market essentially
gapped up and then was right here,
reversed and went higher. Or that's what
I'm looking for because we kind of sold
off overnight. Market opened up right
here and got really overextended.
Um, and so what I'm looking for is that
overextension to fail. And so what I
looked for here was
the market opened up here at 7:30. um
pretty much right here actually. Um and
that's a like a a really good target I
like to do for these trades. But so what
I'm looking at is the market sold off
and then
uh it it was essentially an unhealthy
move. And so with these trades, every
time what I'm looking for with one of
these reversals is that to come down to
one of these levels and in a big way,
the the overall trend needs to show a
potential for reversal. And I want it to
be essentially a final spike that helps
a allow me to jump in and look for a
larger move to the upside that I can
capture.
That's the biggest thing when it comes
to looking for these 15 or 30 minute
reversals is that, you know, I'm looking
for that quick spike, but if the
market's going to have a bigger picture
move, I'm happy to try and stay in and
capture that. And so with this trade
specifically,
what I saw and what I really liked was
we have, you know, a clean downtrend
overnight and then a big flush lower.
And so to me that kind of made it seem a
lot like there was it was a final kind
of bait. A lot of the times
when I have a bias in the overall
market, the big picture bias is very
important I find. And so having the
market
go against that and essentially fake the
other direction in terms of, you know,
if I think that we're at a spot where I
think it's going to reverse, well, if it
kind of does a quick fake in that
direction, I can look as that that's a
trap. You know, a lot of the market's
opening, a lot of people might see a lot
of movement down overnight and they
might think, oh, I can jump in on this
and get in and capture the market
continuing lower. But a lot of the time
I find that instead it fakes out and
reverses higher. And so especially with
it aligning up with a support level down
here, it allows me to look for a lot of
that potential. Um, and so
how I ended up jumping in on this trade,
just to kind of zoom back to the start
quickly just to show you, um, is, you
know, it came down here initially and
then started to slow down, right? And so
this chop right here I really like for
showing that this momentum is
potentially slowing. Now it could be
just a spot like this where there's some
chop and it just continues lower. And so
what keyed me into the potential that
it's going to reverse is well these
candlesticks are really big and then we
have some strong momentum here coming
off of that low. And so what that does
is that makes me realize, okay, could
have a reversal here, but it's not
confirmed yet. I'm not just going to
jump in on this big bullish candlestick.
Another thing to look at here is
flipping between the ES and the NASDAQ.
The NASDAQ is selling off and the ES
selling off. They're both very much
aligned. I think it's very important to
have both markets aligned
for things to play out. I find often if
you know the ES is selling off and the
NASDAQ is kind of flat,
not a good trade is going to happen. Um,
and so what I was watching here is this
red line is that 15-minute reversal
timing. And so what I'm looking at is
well, we've made a nice pullback here.
And so if we're going to continue lower,
I think that's going to be a a important
high right here. And it's going to
continue lower off of that and and make
a new low. But keeping in mind that I'm
looking for potential long if it does
essentially break this high right here.
I think that
it could continue higher and make a
larger reversal in that sense. Um and so
what I'm looking for is essentially to
see what this pullback looks like. You
know, all my trades I don't know what
the pullback's going to look like, when
it's going to have a nice pullback. It's
a lot about trading and waiting for
these is a lot about just being really
open-minded of okay, I see the potential
here. What do I want to see the market
do for me to jump in? If it does this, I
will jump in and if it doesn't do that,
I'll stay out. I find a lot of a good
way to trade is to be really open-minded
about what the market is actually doing
and having it to where you almost are
trying to say, "Hey, you need to show me
something and really good for me to jump
in. Convince me to get in." Versus
FOMOing and trying to find reasons to
get in. find reasons or a lot of reasons
to stay out and have the market have to
really convince you to jump in. And so I
put in a pretty much a a stop order
above that high. So when it made a new
high, I jumped in. I thought that was a
strong enough signal. I didn't wait for
this candlestick to finish forming. Um
sometimes I do that because
I think that there's enough momentum in
the market that if it breaks, I think
it's going to move quickly. Um and so in
this case, I did I just jumped in on a
break of that. um waiting for the candle
close would have made sense or would
have worked in this case too but
sometimes you know you can have a rip
happen really quickly and I thought the
signal was strong enough um and so
that's a decision you can make and then
I used my you know riskreward drawing
tool uh stop below this kind of pullback
here with the idea that if it does pull
back um I you know I want to get out
right uh I I don't think I think that
this is going to work out quickly and
this pullback right here was a big
deciding factor, you know, if it's going
to go higher. It came and tested this
kind of chop range that it had. Um, and
then from there, you know, I'm just
looking to see, okay, is it going to go
back to the market open or is it going
to continue up from there? Um, and so to
kind of zoom forwards in this back to
where we were to show you what was going
on. Um, and as well is right now I
actually have a uh Black Friday sale on
my full course that goes in way more in
depth into this, you know, 10 plus hours
of content talking about how to avoid
how to stay in these trades, how to
capture them properly, how to manage
them properly. Um, and then also the
mental side of trading that is extremely
important to being consistently
successful with this. Um, a lot of
people have really found that important
to actually consistently executing. You
know, if you've looked at some of my
challenges, I have not followed those
very well and it's been very detrimental
to my trading. I've lost a lot of money
because I haven't been um on the right
side of the mental side of trading. I've
got it a lot back recently and I've I've
been able to capture good trades and
focus on my strategy, but it's a lot
harder when you know you let your your
emotions control your actions. So, in
terms of managing this, this was very
fast-paced move up that it had. Um, and
so what I'm looking at, you know, the
initial thought was, okay, market open,
blew right through that. Um, and then
the last thing was I I drew some of
these uh resistance or support zones.
And just to pull a chart up here, what
those were was essentially, okay, these
previous swing lows that the market had
on a bigger picture 15-minute chart. And
so, I'm thinking, hey, maybe we come up
and retest those. You can see that right
there. Um, and so, you know, this was
the the easy money I think was
essentially made up to that level. And
because we have such a parabolic move, I
find when you have parabolic moves, you
have to tighten your stop quickly. I
haven't moved it up. I I have it at
break even, but if the market moves
down, you know, I have a mental stop for
a little while here. But as it, you
know, made this big bar, I thought, hey,
I I if we break this, I definitely want
to get out. Um hopefully I get out
before then, but I also want to give it
some room. Like I want to give it room
to a 50% pullback this uptrend. You know
it it's always a big balance of trying
to manage how you are going to
uh you know emotionally deal with being
in a trade but also manage uh the
potential you know the potential that
this continues to rip higher but the
potential that it also rips higher a
little bit more and then rips back lower
because you know my whole strategy is
seeing unhealthy moves and reversing
those. Well, I'm also capturing an
unhealthy move here and looking for that
potentially reverse can be a problem.
And so, um, you know, kind of just
trailing up my stop here and eventually
getting out if it kind of breaks higher
here, uh, in a in a tricky way. And so,
essentially what happens is I, you know,
it makes a spike higher, almost hits my
limit, um, and then reverses down and
knocks me out. And I call it a day on
that.